[Music]
hi everyone my name is Christine Pasco
and today we're going to be talking
about accelerating compliance with
laboratory software Limbs and
automation today Laboratories are faced
with increasing pressures to generate
high quality data cost effectively And
Timely and there are so many challenges
and Regulatory pressures that are faced
by Laboratories one of the best ways to
address these pressures is through
automation implementing a limbs a
laboratory information management system
helps with not only creating quotes and
sending out invoices but also with
sample tracking printing out automated
chain of custody reports printing
printing out automated final
reports being able to interface all the
instrumentation in the laboratory so
that there's no opportunity for
transcription errors the data comes
right off the instrument and goes into
the limbs so that scientist can
basically validate and approv data which
leads to very quick um turnaround times
and also um the ability to have
automated reports as well as having
automated reports on a client portal
that's available 24/7 this cuts down on
paperwork that the laboratory needs to
deal with um this eliminates calls to
the Laboratories because clients can now
access their own reports and many
Laboratories also post their invoices on
the client portal so that it's a true um
247 user experience um having the right
Tools in place results in higher
customer
satisfaction our agenda today is going
to be looking at introduction to limbs
looking at all the data that there is to
manage um discussing ISO certification
as well as key features and functions in
the limbs power of the limbs plus
Automation and then also automated
reporting all right our learning
objectives for today are to understand
the role of a limbs in a qms or quality
management system and then also learning
about all the other systems that can be
tightly integrated with the limbs so
these systems include Erp systems they
include invoicing or accounting packages
they incl include nutritional labeling
systems if you're doing uh food testing
um so there's so many other systems that
can be integrated uh today it's all
about getting all the data pulled
together rather than having separate
silos of data for a more efficient
management of the operation and also
faster reporting and then finally to
become familiar with key features and
functions of the limbs we talked earlier
about quoting invoicing sample tracking
um positive ID barcoding instrument
integration shelf life studies can be
set up chemical and reagent inventory as
well as um managing resources so employ
training records as well as instrument
calibration maintenance and
repairs there's so many different types
of testing being done everything from
raw material to finished products um
Edibles adds a whole new layer it's a
very uh sophisticated and challenging
Matrix to per per form sample
preparation on and when it's placed in
all these different products it makes it
just a little bit more
interesting why do we test cannabis well
there's several reasons um obvious one
is potency uh the higher potency the
higher the price um there's also testing
done for safety concerns so if there's
bacteria mot toxins pesticides for
chemical agents heavy metals foreign
material any solvents so it's very
important that that the quality of the
product be tested for all these
different
parameters why are limbs critical well
there's so many different data points
that need to be accounted for so when
you're doing testing for water quality
that's being um placed on the plants
that are being grown you're looking for
chemicals in the water that could have a
negative effect on the plants um on the
final product you're looking for a
potency once the product is placed into
different food matrices so it's really
important to manage all this data and
when you're in a laboratory you're not
just managing the unique identifier of
each sample that's being tested but
you're also looking at the quality of
that data and to look at the quality of
that data you need to look at the
chemicals and reagents and supplies that
are used in the laboratory the dates
that they were opened who opened them
what the expiration date is what the lot
number is uh if your instrument is
properly C calibrated when was the last
time it was calibrated um were any U
mainten was any maintenance done on that
piece of equipment when what was the
maintenance so all of that needs to be
tracked as well um looking at your
employee training records who is trained
to perform which test Auditors want to
make sure that the people that are
actually performing the analysis have
proper training so they'll want to see
proof of this training so in the limbs
you can attach copies of training
records or any quizzes that were taken
as part of that training within the
system you can also assign Privileges
and permissions so this ensures that
only certain people can access certain
information so if someone's in login
they don't need to have permissions or
privileges to the QC functionality
within the system um also being able to
go paperless this not only saves time uh
but also cuts down on cost reducing your
carbon footprint it just makes sense
today nobody wants to have binders in
binders and binders of data it's very
hard to access that data and if there's
a fire or something um the paper is
missing that data is lost forever having
it electronically allows there to be
backup of that data and that data can
also be accessed from different
locations people look at different limb
systems it's really important to
understand the different types of
Technology that's available what
language the limbs was written in if
it's in the cloud or on premises
um if it what reporting tools are used
if it's configurable or um if
customization is needed you don't want
to go the customization route because
that makes the limbs that's unique to
your laboratory you want to look for
configurability and flexibility and then
also support is very important I spoke
with someone last week that said they
were paying a lot for the annual support
agreement but the support was horrible
and they were getting very frustrated to
the point where they were looking at
replacing the system so you know never
discount support often times um that's
something that makes or breaks a a
solution because being able to extract
the most value from the system is
critical so the training and support
offerings are key and then also making
sure the systems future prooof so that
in you know two or three years you don't
have to buy a new system because the the
technology has been um outdated look at
the reputation of the provider um
certifications that they hold if they're
in the UK they should have ticket if
they're in the US ISO certifications
from the international standards
organization look at ease of use um is
is it intuitive or is it very difficult
to learn how to use and then make sure
you're understanding the return on
investment the proper due diligence has
been
done when we talk about Cloud hosting
our SAS which stands for software as a
service versus on premises if the system
is on premises your it team is
responsible for securing um the the
server environment making sure there's a
a hardened firewall that your network
switches have software that's been
updated um making sure that all the
connections to the server
are operating as designed making sure
that each user can see the server making
sure the backups are done um daily
making sure that there's monitoring and
maintenance going on of that uh server
environment when it's in the cloud um
all that is taken care of for you all
you need is a solid internet connection
so the vendor's responsible for
automatic updates to your test Dev
environment um answering any support
questions making sure that the daily
backups are done so there's there's pros
and cons to each we really see a huge
move toward the cloud it just makes
sense financially because it is more
cost affordable than building everything
on your own fa on your own uh facility
just because you can leverage um the
cost of you know many many people set
being set up in the
cloud looking at sample tracking and
inventory control um barcoding is very
popular and very powerful um not only
does it allow people to uh scan many
samples quickly but it's also very
accurate um it allows Laboratories to go
paperless and that um they can basically
scan the samples throughout the labor
atory for those people that like to have
paper for for example um Ben Sheets or
work list if as they're often called you
can basically set up your run and then
scan all the samples into the system the
system will create the um the work list
send it electronically to the instrument
the instrument can run all the samples
send the work list back to the limbs and
that results in a very efficient process
and very rapid results it also allows
people to track the samples in real
time dashboards are very powerful as
they include key performance indicators
so a laboratory manager might have
different kpis than uh analyst and
analyst may want to know what their back
log is um they might may be interested
in their work list for the day where a
lab manager May care about the
turnaround time of the laboratory or tat
um the manager May care about the
workload um do they have enough staff
and instrumentation to manage the
samples that are coming in so the beauty
of dashboards is that everyone can see
what's important to them um managers and
directors can also take a look at you
know financial information in terms of
who's the largest customer who who um
you know who's behind on their invoices
so there's a lot of of information
that's available on the
dashboard instrument integration is
increasingly becoming important uh today
today we don't do a project that doesn't
involve instrument integration it just
makes Financial sense you don't want to
have highly trained resources entering
results into uh a spreadsheet or into a
limbs it it doesn't make sense everyone
uh that's listening to this call is a
knowledge worker and we need to work
smarter so you know by having the
instruments integrated with the limbs
not only does it increase accuracy in
throughput it avoids you know entering
data into multiple systems and also has
a very fast Roi I've seen it as fast as
3 months uh but typical is 6 to9 months
based on your sample um sample uh
workflow and how many samples you're
analyzing how does it work uh it's
really pretty straightforward we look
for a CSV or comma separated value an
Excel file or text whatever that
instrument puts out unfortunately
there's no standardization in instrument
exports so every instrument puts out a
different format in a different order
and then what can be done is a parser
can be created that takes that output
file and rearranges it to put it into a
file that the limbs is expecting so it
can be automatically imported and the
same can be done with data that's sent
out to subcontracting Laboratories so
that that data can automatically be
imported in the limbs as well so I often
talk with Laboratories that send out
tests that they don't do and I say well
where does that data go and sadly it
often ends up in a file cabinet or on a
folder on a share Drive in a PDF format
um that data should be pulled in with
the rest of the data for that sample so
that all the data is in one location so
that you can do some statistical
analysis look at some business
intelligence look at you know data like
how many um tests did we do of all the
different types how much work was sent
out what did it cost us so that manager
managers can make decisions on when it
makes sense to bring testing in
house another area that's rapidly
expanding is the use of sensors sensor
technology is truly the future with
sensors you can record things such as
temperature light humidity and all that
data um is backed up into the cloud so
the way this system works is it takes
readings every 15 seconds it has this
dashboard and the cloud that can be
accessed anywhere and then it's linked
to the limbs so that for an auditor in
the limbs it'll place the max the Min
and the average temperature for that day
for microbiology samples it'll actually
take two readings four hours apart and
place that data in the limb so what this
does is make Laboratories bulletproof
for their audits another nice thing is
that it's cheap insurance on your
equipment because if the temperature
dips below a preset limit that you've
set it'll actually send an alert to your
cell phone and also send out an email
and you can also have a cc list so not
only does it monitor the health of your
equipment but it also gives you an alert
if there's going to be a problem and if
you um have a lot of kits or reagents
consumables in your fridge or freezer I
know I did when I worked in the
laboratory it was very expensive if a
refrigerator went down over the weekend
and everything was lost um it also
eliminates paper so with with sens it's
really going to change the future and
it's going to take away a lot of the
mundane tasks that doesn't make sense
for people to do U the other thing
that's worth mentioning is the
thermocouples that are n certified and
they can be calibrated remotely or sent
in um for the
certificate now if we look at the total
solution all the different elements of
the
limbs what we can see is that you have
an underlying database whether it's um
you know SQL server or Oracle it's an
SQL structured query language database
that all the data it's a has referential
Integrity all the data resides in and
you know Laboratories are under
increased pressure to track everything
just the metadata with the sample the
unique ID for the sample all the
descriptive information on when and
where the sample was collected who
collected it with all the date and time
stamps uh there's support for barcoding
so that labels can automatically be
generated the ability to look at uh
dashboards with a data grid the ability
to create an unlimited number of custom
reports your certificate of analysis
report um and these reports are one
thing that can set Laboratories apart
from each other because if you think
about it at the end of the day the
report is your final product uh there's
so much that goes on behind the scenes
to generate that report but it's very
important that the report is
userfriendly easy to understand um make
sense quickly to the client so that they
don't have to discide Cipher or you know
hunt for the result and the QC data uh
there's also the ability to schedule
studies so if you have to collect
samples at a specific time or if you
need to do shelf life studies on your um
finished products you can also set those
up and it can send out reminders via
email also can log in what test needs to
be performed uh you can also have
integration with different
instrumentation um this again this just
makes sense we covered that earlier so
that data is electronically being
uploaded to the SQL database there's no
opportunity for transcription errors and
then the ability to automatically email
print or fax if anyone's still doing
that um from the
system and then past the firewall you
have additional functionality with
iMobile Solutions leveraging mobile
technology if you need to collect data
in the field do Q QC checks at the plant
um then also a client portal so that 247
clients can not only access their
results um but also download locked PDF
reports of their CFA they can download
uh PDFs of their invoice so it allows
the laboratory to do business
247 now if we look at key features in
the internal chain of custody this is
very important in Laboratories that are
dealing with controled substances so you
want to make sure that you manage and
monitor
the samples as it's going through the
laboratory testing process so if you
receive the sample there's a formal
receipt process with date and time
stamps who received the sample where the
sample is placed how much of the sample
was received if someone removes the
sample to perform testing on it how much
sample they removed what is the
remaining sample volume and then also
when samples are disposed of that's also
very important to track that um so it's
very important to understand the
importance of the internal chain of
custody and make sure that everyone in
the laboratory is trained on best
practices the ability to look at data
with um statistical analysis software is
incredibly powerful and today there are
even AI tools that can be leveraged so
having all the data first of all in one
secure SQL database is critical and then
running uh statistical analysis tools
against that database for a subset of
data that's been quered is also amazing
in terms of being able to view trends
that you may not have been aware of and
then also having integrated charting to
look at Trends in the data how how the
samples are performing over time if
you're looking at a particular field um
or a finish product so there's a lot of
information to be minded In The Raw data
um data entry and Reporting it's all
about speed so if you're doing a high
volume of samples looking at batch order
login um most of the data is coming off
of instruments I'd say for our
Laboratories probably 90% plus of the
data is coming in automatically from
instruments um for microbiology and some
other tests where there is no instrument
or there's a subjective interpretation
that data must be added by hand but for
the most part it's automated um rapid
accessioning of samples so being able to
barcode in samples where kits were sent
out for collection and when they come
back in they can be very quickly scanned
sending out an automated certificate of
analysis report and invoice report um is
huge in terms of Time Savings there's no
um mailing cost there's no paper cost
printer cost toner cost that's all
pushed to the portal clients can access
that themselves again eliminating paper
and then having higher customer
satisfaction um this is an example of
just a a typical can CFA report um it
basically list all the parameters and
you can see it's really easy to see um
the results of the test you can even
leverage colors if you want to highlight
any test that exceeded limits that were
set up um you can also digitize
signature so that when the user logs
into the system it'll know who that user
is and insert their digit signature into
that report as the approver of those
results and not only does automated
reporting save time but it also results
in increased accuracy and higher
customer satisfaction because they can
get their results
faster CRM um being able to access data
in real time is huge so allowing clients
to log into the portal and see the
status of their testing so they can see
see that the sample has been received
the results have been entered but they
haven't been validated yet um if you
want to turn that on for them to see or
you can just um turn it to the position
so they only see validated approved
results there's a lot of different
options many customers also require
electronic data deliverables these can
also be
shared as an attachment to the um client
portal instead of having a locked PDF
you can have a Excel file shared or a
CSV output um they can also see the
sample status if they have multiple
samples through the system they can um
query the database and look at the
history of the samples that they've sent
so it's a very powerful tool there's
also a limbs kiosk where clients can
send their results to the laboratory
247 um provide credit card information
for prepaid samples this allows the
laboratory to know what samples are
coming to be
analyzed
uh we talked a little before about
mobile technology this is also a very
significant time in costs saver it
allows Laboratories to receive data from
field tests that are done whether it's
you know pH or moisture or any type of
checks that the
laboratory um offers this not only saves
in time but it also reduces the number
of paper amount of paper that's used um
reduces cost because there's no need to
enter data from paper forms into the
limbs and the beauty is this can be um
leveraged on rugged laptops on tablets
on iPhones um it's really a
GameChanger and Limbs and laboratory
process automation it's all about at the
end of the day high data Integrity
having high data quality because you
want to have results that are real um in
getting Real Results you have to track
all the other information in the
laboratory in terms of was the
instrument calibrated was the analyst
trained were the reagents um in Spec
were they um expired or you know when
when was the bottle opened of the
standard all that information needs to
be tracked and traced um Laboratories
that can manage their time more
efficiently are going to see higher
customer satisfaction rates higher
efficiency as well as profitability and
all this needs to be done um making sure
that you know you're in compliance with
all the Reg ation cannabis Laboratories
um need to be ISO 17025 certified be
aware of Laboratories that don't have
the certification because this is
critical um and then they also have to
have integration with a number of other
packages for State reporting such as
metrics so it's important that you have
a solid solution in place in the
laboratory to manage the samples and
that everyone in the laboratory
understands the role of the different
types of tech technology and work
smarter there's many many benefits to
automation um they begin with being able
to automatically generate high quality
reports um being able to pull up data
during an audit whether it's a chain of
custody or whether if it it's an in
invoice report or final analysis report
um making sure that there's Security in
the system that each user has a role in
a profile and they've been set up in the
system to access just the data that they
need and not data that they shouldn't be
having access to the ability to generate
work list so analysts always know
exactly what work is needed um backlog
reports so that managers can see which
work is waiting to be completed um being
able to manage instrument calibration
data um and employee training records
being able to have all of the key
instruments interfaced into the limbs
for you know cost savings and high
higher data
Integrity been managing your chemical
and reagent inventory in the laboratory
as well as complaints against the
laboratory with corrective and
preventative actions um surveying
customers periodically to make sure that
everything that the laboratory is doing
is working well and then also looking at
Advanced analytics and trending um what
is the data telling you what additional
Services can you offer to your clients
in terms of letting them look at their
historical data and then also having all
that data securely stored um over time
if anyone has the need to go back a few
years and u pull a report that they may
have lost and then the ability for
automatic notifications alerts and
emails is a huge
timesaver summary the right limbs is
critical as well as automation for the
Cannabis Testing Lab today it costs
probably $2 and half to $3 million to
start a lab from scratch so it's
critical that you have the key Tools in
place to operate efficiently there's a
lot of pressure not just regulatory but
business competition so those
Laboratories that operate um lean and
have the tools in place to ensure that
they're not wasting their resources are
going to be the ones that Survive and
Thrive and then also looking at you know
doing everything on um premises versus
the cloud the cloud is much more cost
effective it has 99 99% uptime
guarantees it can be accessed anywhere
there's an secure internet connection um
and then also looking at eliminating
mundane tasks for users such as you know
dual entry printing out labels by hand
um automating reporting are all huge
huge huge Time
Savers and other um advantages are
having better communication across the
organization so having everyone be able
to log in to view data rather than a lot
of phone calls or emails back and forth
saves time and money um making sure that
um the facilities are compliant so ISO
17025 making sure they're prepared for
their audits um other options are single
sign on or multiactor authentication for
security of the data um the limbs must
also be 20 uh1 CFR part 11 compliant so
that there's full support for electronic
records and then also have a
comprehensive audit train as well as the
internal chain of
custody